the cakes Crusaders ongoing film saga
ranks among the top five highest
grossing movie franchises in the United
States but he's also faced his share of
setbacks along the way if every fad
blockbuster that made its way to see it
as does it take on the character that's
unceremoniously died in development
here's the history of every one of those
councils Batman movies the Batman
getting Tim Burton's 1989 Batman onto
the big screen was a difficult process
ten years before Michael Keaton made his
Dark Knight debut produces Benjamin
Banneker and Michael Uslan acquired the
film rights to Batman so they could
adapt the character in the same vein as
Superman they wanted to have a
definitive dark version of Batman on
film and produces John Peters and Peter
Guber agreed when they boarded the
project in November 1979 four years
later the script by James Bond and
Superman screenplay co-writer Tom
mankiewicz simply titled the Batman was
completed focusing on Batman and Robin's
origins with the Joker as the central
villain while the Batman slash
double-oh-seven version of that man
would have been awesome the project went
through multiple developers and
producers losing bits and pieces along
the way in the end the studio hired Tim
Burton to direct who felt the treatment
was too similar to Superman and would be
a better fit for a TV series he changed
virtually every aspect of the movie so
while they didn't get everything they
wanted the producers still got their
darker version of that man on the silver
screen it just took a decade to make it
happen
Robin spin-off when Chris O'Donnell
joined the franchise as Robin for 1995
Batman Forever
he seemed poised for a long run as the
character he returned for 1997 Batman
and Robin and planned to reprise his
role in a possible first film but that
never came to fruition Warner Brothers
also briefly pursued a Robin spin-off
which O'Donnell confirmed as recently as
2012 as he told Access Hollywood they
were going to do a Robin movie back in
the day then Batman
Robin was such a bomb they were like
scrap that that was the end of that
Batman Unchained Joel Schumacher told
variety that he'd always planned to make
three Batman movies but unfortunately
for everyone involved in Schumacher's
bat saga Batman and Robin
tanked sending the franchise into years
of development hell and leaving that
third movie unrealized the problems
weren't just at the box office however
Akiva Goldsman who wrote the screenplays
for Schumacher's first to bat flicks
opted not to return for the next
installment I am Legend screenwriter
Mark Protosevich took Golden's place and
came up with the name Batman Unchained
which focused on Scarecrow is the
central villain Schumacher wanted
Nicolas Cage to play the fear inducing
bad guy saying that he owed the world
quote a real Batman movie but Batman and
Robin crashed and burned taking Batman
unchanged whether changing course
completely Warner Brothers started
looking into the idea of making up
Batman Beyond all Batman year one film
instead Batman Dark Knight Riders Lee
Shapiro and Steven wise had an idea for
a full bat reboot this time instead of
Batman and Robin in their primes the duo
wanted to see Batman retired with Dick
Grayson attending college in the
proposed film dr. Jonathan crane better
known as the Scarecrow still played a
prominent role as professor of
psychology at Gotham University also
appearing dr. Kirk Langstrom who turns
into the monstrous man bat the two
doctors get into a confrontation and
crane accidentally initiates Kirk's
transformation into his bat like form
after seeing man bat terrorized Gotham
and the city's residents are mistaking
him for the real Batman The Dark Knight
comes out of retirement to clear his
name the doctor idea was pitched to the
studio but after being passed through
multiple levels of approval and a few
confirmations from producers the
studio's director of development passed
on the movie Batman year one Schumacher
still wanted to give Batman fans of
proper caped crusader and his planned
adaptation of Frank Miller's Batman year
one might have fulfilled that goal
ultimately the studio parted ways with
shumar
car and went with requiem for a dream
director Darren Aronofsky instead after
hiring Aronofsky the studio bolstered
the project's pedigree further by
bringing Frank Miller himself on board
to script in an interview with IGN
Aronofsky urged fans to quote tot out
everything you can imagine about Batman
everything we're starting completely in
new unfortunately the studio didn't get
into Miller's version of the script so
they hired that which asked ease of
matrix things to write a treatment again
the studio wasn't satisfied so they came
to Joss Whedon whose take also didn't
pass muster with the studio they finally
ended up Sheldon the idea altogether in
2002 Batman Beyond Warner Brothers also
floated the idea of making a Batman
Beyond film inspired by the hit animated
show which had debuted in 1999 Bruce
Timm and Paul Dini series featured Terry
McGinnis a teenager who takes over the
mantle of Batman under the guidance of a
retired Bruce Wayne the studio's movie
division liked Batman Beyond so much
because they wanted to make a
live-action version for the big screen
they hired Remember the Titans director
Bo has shaken to helmed the project with
Dini writing the script sources told
variety in 2000 that a Batman Beyond
film didn't interview with one of others
plans to continue with a fifth Batman
movie but that changed quickly
by August 2001 Dini said that the studio
had shelved the live-action adaptation
once more later that year the Batman
Beyond animated series was cancelled
Batman vs Superman Asylum long before
Zack Snyder's Batman vs Superman dawn of
Justice hit the big screens Warner
Brothers previously had plans to pit the
DC universes two biggest heroes against
each other
Andrew Kevin Walker who pens the
incredibly dark seven pitched an idea
that involved Batman coming out of
retirement shortly after his wife's
death to join a recently divorced
Superman
until of course they're duped by Lex
Luthor into fighting each other sound
familiar
Akiva Goldsman returning to the
franchise once more revised Walker's
script in 2002 which was enough to
convince Warner Brothers to move for
would with the project at least for a
little while
Wolfgang Petersen director of Air Force
One and the neverending story intended
to direct the film in 2003 but the
project was derailed when JJ Abrams
jumped into the fray with a script for a
movie called Superman flyby which
included a very different version of the
Man of Steel
according to Peterson the studio decided
to try separate versions of Superman and
Batman instead resulting in Superman
Returns and Batman Begins Justice League
mortal 2017 Justice League wasn't the
first attempt to bring Batman and the
rest of the league to the big screen in
2009 the first plan to bring DC's heroes
together came awfully close to hitting
theaters written by Kieran and Michelle
Mulroney Justice League mortal was to be
humped by Mad Max director George Miller
it's cast included DJ cotrona as
Superman army Hamas Batman
megan Gale as Wonder Woman Adam Brody as
the flash common is Green Lantern and
Teresa Palmer as Talia al Ghul with Jay
Baruchel playing the villain Maxwell
Lord cameras were ready to roll but the
writers strike of the late 2000s put a
damper on the movie the overwhelming
success of Christopher Nolan's The Dark
Knight convinced Warner Brothers that a
Justice League with a different Batman
simply wouldn't work Justice League
mortals is the Justice League movie that
never was so when you're watching Ben
Affleck Throwdown with Khal Drogo just
think about how much crazier it would
have been if the director of Mad Max had
gotten to the league first
I wanted a what a lovely day thanks for
watching
good to lubricants and subscribe to our
YouTube channel Plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]